Occasionally, Fox News host Chris Wallace
will bring us some kind of like heroic journalism
by American standards, but it's really what
in other countries would just be called journalism.
And today's is perfect because it shows us
how easily a talking point that spreads like
wildfire can be exposed and debunked.
If reporters are actually willing to do it
in many, many are not, or at least they're
not well-prepared enough to do it.
And the talking point in this case is that
stimulus checks are going to prisoners.
Republicans have, among other things, been
saying Democrats and Joe Biden are sending
stimulus checks to people in prison and some
senators say it and then right wing media
says it.
And then before you know it, it's being repeated
by Republican voters in diners, the likes
of which we saw in clips earlier today.
The truth, of course, is that prisoners got
stimulus money during the first covid stimulus
package and during the second covid stimulus
package.
It's how they work.
It's not set up to exclude people who are
otherwise income eligible just because they're
in prison now.
Maybe it could be done logistically, but a
court has actually said, no, you can't do
it.
And so radical Republican Senator Tom Cotton
pulls this bullet point and Chris Wallace
confronts him.
Check out Tom Cotton's defense and Chris Wallace
confronting Tom Cotton with his own previous
words here.
Here is one of your other complaints about
the covid relief bill.
Take a look, sir.
How crazy some of the Democratic ideas are,
I mean, they had a chance on Saturday morning
to stop checks from going to prisoners, from
going to the Boston bomber, for instance.
And on that vote, they declined.
Every single Democrat wanted to continue the
practice of sending checks to prisoners.
But Senator, under two previous covid related
bills that you supported and voted for and
the president runs on prisoners also got checks
in those bills.
Well, Chris, that was obviously never Congress's
intent.
The Trump administration, IRS and Treasury
Department did not send checks to prisoners.
Liberal advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge that they had to last
month was that far.
This month was the first time we ever had
a simple up or down vote on whether those
checks should go to prisoners.
And the simple fact is that every Democrat
voted to keep sending checks to prisoners.
I don't think that's a smart idea.
I suspect most Americans don't either.
So notice how Tom Cotton tries like a mini
Gish Gallop there.
Gish Gallop is where you throw a bunch of
stuff out and it's sort of all together.
Sounds like, wow, that's a lot.
But then when you start going through each
claim, you realize there's nothing there.
First, Tom Cotton concedes.
OK, yes.
Stimulus checks went to prisoners during Trump's
covid stimulus.
No one checks went to prisoners during Trump's
covid stimulus number two.
And now checks are going to prisoners during
the third stimulus under Joe Biden.
But says Tom Cotton, during the first and
second ones, it wasn't our intent.
We didn't want them to go to prisoners this
time.
Democrats do want the checks to go to prisoners.
It was never their intention, he says, but
they did it twice and then they only are making
a big deal out of it the third time when Joe
Biden is president and Democrats control the
Senate.
But then Tom Cotton says this is the first
time we actually had an up or down vote on
it and it passed.
Well, that's because you guys controlled the
Senate before and you didn't want an up and
down vote.
But more importantly, the up and down vote
this time was irrelevant because it's already
been decided on previously by a federal judge,
the IRS inspector general, previously after,
I believe it was after the second stimulus
bill, might have been the first.
I think it was the second the IRS inspector
general confirmed that they did send checks
to prisoners during one of the earlier stimulus
packages.
And because there were no restrictions on
people in jail or prison getting the money,
the IRS later was pressured to change their
position.
And the IRS said, you know what, prisoners
don't qualify for the release checks.
And if anybody got one, they should send the
money back.
So prisoners filed a class action lawsuit
against the IRS.
And the treasury secretary and a federal judge
ruled on this in September.
The court ruling said you can't withhold coronavirus
relief payments if prisoners qualify from
an income standpoint just because they are
incarcerated, a federal judge decided.
So this up and down vote now was meaningless
in the end.
And recall that prisoners have to buy their
own hygiene products.
They pay exorbitant rates just to make phone
calls.
That's another big scam that preys on prisoners,
which we've talked about.
Give them the stimulus money, guys.
We're talking about stimulus money that went
to hundreds of millions of people.
There's a couple million prisoners that that
this applied to.
Let's not stand in the way.
But more importantly, Tom Cotton is such a
hypocrite and his defense is so, you know,
I want to say it's so obviously bogus.
If it weren't for Chris Wallace saying, whoa,
whoa, whoa, stop the clock here, a lot of
people probably would fall for Tom Cotton's
explanation.
And in fact, many people do because they see
Chris Wallace and they're like, that's like
when Shep Smith was on Fox.
He's the one guy you can't trust on Fox News.
That's unfortunately the perspective of of
many of these right wing Fox viewers.
But the talking point falls apart so quickly
and yet it still spreads like wildfire.
So nice job, mostly by Chris Wallace.
This is just kind of called journalism in
many other countries, but I would have like
to see him push back even more.